[Music]
you know God from the fiery depths of
apocalypse noted for classification
[Music]
you can't have earth Brainiac it would
say I'm better under your regime in
every way
[Music]
[Applause]
hooha
who is it we need to tell now earth's
defenses irreversibly compromised
he killed the countdown
Oh
I am Brainiac
I seek the one you called Superman you
have no idea what Brainiac can do years
I believed like a destroyed Krypton
you're afraid of them how do I beat him
you can't
Superman supply focus and oversight I
must correct
I collect worlds and then I discard to
remnants
I'm not you're straight you cannot match
my intellect
allow me to give you a proper
demonstration
you have a plan it's a work in progress
first climate zone
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so many
injustice to bombs being dropped there's
so much stuff happening so I will do a
new round of the injustice to giveaway
because the game is so close to coming
out and there are some really cool tips
on how to upgrade your gear if you don't
want to play PvP there's a really cool
multiverse single-player storyline so if
you're big RPG fan like me and you want
to do a lot of questing they have a
version of that too where you can get
exclusive gear that will help you during
your PvP matches but as part of the new
gear system they have a bunch of
different loadout so it's just like
playing a normal MMO like Warcraft you
have your raid gear you have your PvP
gear you have your single-player
questing gear so the gear is really cool
but when you get really serious about it
certain gear will just help you in
certain types of matches against certain
types of villains like darkside I know
they're billing Brainiac is the big
villain of the story arc for injustice -
he's a new big bad that comes in in the
wake of all the stuff that happens
between Batman and Superman steams and I
love the way they're teasing Batman
having to work with Superman because
Brainiac is so much more dangerous for
them all he needs domination for the
entire world so you capture Superman
you're going to let them right back out
it's so funny they teased a lot of
shifting alliances in the game but
here's their community specialist
talking a little bit about the specifics
of the multiverse mode it's actually
really cool multiverse now ed touched on
it a little bit the multiverse is now
there are players out there who may not
want to just go online and play against
people they would really want some
really solid single-player content and
the multiverse is a place for that like
you mentioned there's all of these
different earths that have different
kind of storylines with some context for
them and you're able to play through
those and different different kind of
challenges and chapters and when get
gear that you can only find in the
multiverse so this is a really good way
to get gear especially if you're like me
and I'm really terrible playing it
against other people and it's very
intimidating and I get scared so this is
actually really good mode for somebody
who doesn't want the stress right it's a
good boat for that and maybe even get
better why exactly so because a lot of a
lot of the different earths have these
sort of different objectives you have to
accomplish them T know kind of keep
training you up in the game and the cool
thing that I really like is it's almost
like a huge cycle
so like there's one that like maybe you
can only use Batman right and there's
one that you can only use this character
or you have to have this level of gear
so you're always kind of bouncing
between multiverse and multiverse always
finding a new way to unlock something
like okay I did this a lot of all the
characters will have their own sort of
really premier one which will give you
some really excellent gear one thing I
also want to mention that's kind of cool
is we've talked about loadouts in our
gear so you can have like your player
versus player loadout you can also even
create like a multiverse loadout because
there is some gear that will help you in
multiverses to help you maybe get more
experience or more coins or things like
that so on earth 83-61 Superman is a
villains tyrant while General Zod fights
for truth and justice help Zod ensue in
Superman's reign of terror Zod will
assist you via the multiverse portal oh
this is cool
so there's a particular like there is a
story for every plant and as you'll see
we'll hear it like if I'm able to finish
this I can get different mother boxes
which you get gear from as well
I'll also receive credits and then over
here you have to complete the one before
this and you'll get a silver mug the box
at the end of this so it looks like we
also had six planets right we've got six
plants yes I go through and so this this
one itself has a bunch of different
levels you have to get through like this
one you have to be level 15 it's a level
15 character to play the final one so
the game is out May 16th we have a
couple more weeks to go in there are 31
character slots on the website so far
they've only revealed 29 but there was a
leak Joker gameplay so I'm guessing the
east 30 in the reverse-flash wasn't on
the list that I was reading off of so
technically he's a bit of a premium skin
so we'll see if there's like one more
character after the Joker they reveal so
you save some of the best for last and
the Joker as a character would just
enjoy the chaos of what's going on here
so much within the narrative he is
probably having more fun than any of
these other characters just watching the
world burn
so let me know what's your favorite part
about all this who's your favorite
character so far I'm still a big fan of
the flash but I do love all this new
Darkseid gameplay
speaking of Mark Hamill - what's going
to happen later today is as the new Star
Wars suppose in American Gods is
premiering on Sunday it is going to be
hardcore so it might not be later
tonight it might be Saturday but
I'll do an American Gods trailer video
just for everybody that has absolutely
no idea what that is so should be coming
really soon while you wait for that you
can click here for brand-new Wonder
Woman footage of Aries they finally show
them off and you can click here for a
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching let's I thought I'll see you
guys tonight